[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
soonnight tulle est d'abord d'espoir
dans le doing match et exportent est
suspect
[Musique]
les oies à droite toi tu y as a way
fait chier cette allemagne
[Musique]
non
oddo
le relais 4 x 400 c'était notre course
quatre équipiers des millions de
molécules d'adrénaline 8 jambes et un
seul coeur
chacun de nous donner tout ce qu'il
avait pour passer le témoin à suivre ce
jour là le dernier coureur avait dû
rattraper les quelques précieuses
secondes que nous autres avions perdu en
nous laissant distraire par les
atteintes nuit
avec sa poitrine de rêve et ses bas
résille ou le voyez quel dans les
gradins
il ne nous en a pas tenu rigueur il
savait que nous comptions sur lui et ne
nous a pas déçus
[Musique]
peu importe le retard accumulé parce que
dans notre équipe on avait le meilleur
finisseur qui soit
[Musique]
tout le monde en voiture
attention à la marche malades
[Musique]
ce comprend pas il était à sa dirigée
moi ça à cause de ces groll il y avait
des pompes de ville t'as pas vu
j'ai surtout vu comment il courait il a
pas perdu la forme il a raté son train
et il sera en retard au boulot tout le
reste que ce soit c'est chaud sur sa
condition physique n'a aucune importance
une faux papiers toniutti personnes ta
vie tu jamais en soirée et je peux
savoir ce que tu me reproches au juste
rien je suis réaliste non raté jaloux
lui
tout ça parce qu'il a encore la hargne
et que toi tu enlèves des amygdales pour
ta gouverne on s'occupe pas trop des
amis table en orthopédie il a baissé les
bras
arrive à tout le monde devrait pas
manger aussi gras si à cause de ses
chaussures ça peut être assurée il a pas
baissé les bras
non c'est pas son genre
[Musique]
je n'ai pas vu à la réunion on a hérité
du budget lyxor alors si tu as e minute
ce serait bien qu'il y ça non ok lyxor
c'est noté en fait on a rien à battre
comment ça tu en a rien à battre de ce
qu'on fait ici de notre travail
assurance maritime ça te dit quelque
chose et tu sais berti quand tu grandis
alan gayle hand comme moi tu as tiré par
tous qui maritime seulement m'avait pas
dit que ce goulot aurait aucun rapport
avec la mer où les bateaux mais
aujourd'hui me v'là échoué en haut d'une
tour tu te rends compte que dans cette
boîte mais sûrement le seul qui fument
encore oui et je suis victime de
discrimination a tu veux que je te dise
ce qui fait la grandeur de ce pays
broadway ses comédies musicales et j'y
allais souvent avec mes vieux ça me
changeait un peu de notre banlieue
huppée
oklahoma web wind comme sweeping dong
plein
toutes ces chansons sont porteuses d'un
message d'espoir d'amour a surtout
averti je te joue pas la sérénade je
préfère de loin les filles même si je
dois avouer que ton regard bleu azur ne
me laisse pas indifférent
ok déjà ses portes et maintenant tu es
gentil tu mettes 1 ça tu te mets au
boulot écoute je suis plus jeune que toi
je suis arrivé ici après toi et pourtant
j'ai déjà eu deux promotions
tu sais pourquoi parce que moi je ne me
laisse pas aller et si tu crois y être
quelqu'un de classe pas tout faux
vous devriez faire de l'exercice à la
place aucun problème je peux faire les
deux en même temps
et voilà combien de fois de vrais jeux
vous répétait qu un voyageur qui somnole
a de fortes chances de manquer son arrêt
aux safa toute façon le train s'arrête
avant l'atlantique
il y à du hockey ce soir je dois faire à
manger à ma mère tiens mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ça là je vois des tribunes
des vendeurs de confiserie des caméras
ça m'a tout l'air d'être le madison
square garden ce soir de place juste
derrière la vitre pour vous et votre
mère les deux plus grandes fans
cantonaise des rangers
comme si j'avais pu oublier la femme la
plus importante de ma vie
vous êtes à la fois géniale et pas très
malin
je vous remercie de me le rappeler
[Musique]
c'est pas cette tête berti
ce soir c'est la fête
[Musique]
ce
m
beaucoup
j'ai mis un peu de temps mais je suis la
maman chat je t'adore
j'adore travailler dans un bureau et
j'adore être ton mari non merci
tu as oublié un sérère je sais qu'en ce
moment tu es très occupé joyeux
anniversaire de mariage
ah d'accord tu veux qu'on fait ça dans
la chambre d'amis
tu te souviens comment on devait
l'appeler au départ la chambre des
enfants
déjà qu'on n'arrive même pas à faire
s'asseoir le chien
non je plaisante et sérieusement je me
sens prêt c'est vrai quand je te regarde
ça me fait penser que la vie vaut la
peine d'être vécue
et qu'il faut se lancer dedans même si
on ne comprend pas toujours le sens
j'ai reçu une offre du musée de boston
ce serait pour commencer dès cet automne
c'est pour être conservatrice adjointe
j'ai bien réfléchi et si je veux aller
de l'avant il faut que je m'éloigne de
toi
dis moi tout est ce que je le connais
c'est quelqu'un que tu as rencontré au
travail un gros client fan d'art moderne
je suppose que tu ne me quitte pas sur
un coup de tête
alors qui sait très bien si ça peut
aider à comprendre
il y a quelqu'un d'autre
quelqu'un qui me conforte dans ma
décision
c'est dur j'ai pu comprendre ça arrive à
tout le monde
tu a cédé à la tentation tu as fait une
erreur je crois qu'il vaudrait mieux
pour toi comme pour moi que je quitte
cette maison non non non j'ai une
meilleure idée je prends un appartement
de la boîte pas longtemps histoire de
mettre un peu de distance entre nous
c'est bien ça non la distance est comme
ça tu auras la maison pour toi tout seul
et tu verras qu'on n'est pas capable de
vivre l'un sans l'autre
au fait c'était il ya quinze jours quoi
notre anniversaire de mariage
comment il était au téléphone il avait
l'air triste
non bien les quais comme d'habitude
peut-être le cliché d'acheter ça j'ai
les crocs ton pote à des ennuis et toi
tu manges ils font juste une pause c'est
pas la mort pose pourquoi je veux dire
ils sont très bien ensemble
pourquoi ils ont besoin de se séparer je
m'inquiète pour lui je m'inquiète vous
avoir club fait du mouron pour rien mais
alors comment ces vieux or vous êtes
venus ça fait plaisir
tu croyais qu'on était nécessaire c'est
pas notre genre
m je vous présente mes amis partis à
géant de la littérature contemporaine
mais en fait j'écris des articles pour
un magazine automobile équipe un
musicien au talent immense je fais
surtout des singles pour la radio buvez
ce café et vous serez bluffés ils sont
trop modestes et voici
caroline elle travaille à la bourse ça
dans l'arbitrage et j'ai toujours pas
compris ce que ce fait aucune importance
bon si j'allais nous prendre une table
bien pour 4 allez je vous attends la
baraka
c'est qui au juste qu'est ce que ça peut
te faire tu vois pas qui les sets
conclus et j'essaie pas de conclure
cette fille c'est juste une bombe
atomique
il paie marié ça va pas dire servile et
plus avec elle c'est provisoire
la juste besoin d'un peu de temps
combien de temps
c'est pour qu'elles réalisent qu'ils me
préfère à ce mec quel mec
wahou attends une minute phoebe s'envoie
en l'air avec un autre tu plaisantes
ça m'a fait un choc aussi quand elle me
l'a dit vous venez chez soi fera quoi
c'est tout désirez-vous autre chose
remettez mosa vous en prenez un wii ware
vous tenez bien l'alcool
je veux dire vous reprenez a doublé vous
avez l'air parfaitement parfaite vous
trouvez et ces messieurs eux n'ont rien
merci il faut qu'on y aille à quoi on
doit rentrer en train le temps va déjà
pas si il est à eau
vous n'êtes pas marrant les gars rester
c'est ma tournée désolé il faut qu'on
trace mais on vient à peine à les
enrôler ce qu une bonne fin de soirée au
michael si jamais tu as envie de parler
tu me passe un coup de bigot à kenta
d'alors caroline maïs mills à votre
petit nom vous dit que c'est pas des
vins henry ou chuck
ok donc caroline et qu'est ce que je
veux dire je cherche le mot juste
vous connaissez l'histoire de don
quichotte son truc c'était de raconter à
qui voulait l'entendre que c'était ma
chevalier ambitieux héroïque qui
parcourt l espagne alors qu'en réalité
son casque était en carton pâte et qu'il
se battait contre des moulins à vent
parce que comment je pourrais nasa voilà
j'aime j'ai une femme depuis quelques
années mais pas de maîtresse pour
l'instant je savais que je ne courait
aucun risque avec vous aucun risque pour
les mst
c'est pour ça qu'on est là
ouais je suppose qu'avec moi vous courez
aucun risque mais voyez vous l'ennui
c'est que j'ai toujours des sentiments
pour ma femme est bien que
provisoirement soit je serais incapable
de et qu'une autre femme
je veux dire je pourrai jamais vous
engager ouais c'est ça qui a parlé de
s'engager
[Musique]
je suis rentré je sèche vite plus là
mais je voudrais qu'on discute
[Musique]
désolé je voulais pas faire de bruit nom
de dieu qu'est-ce que ça va rien de
cassé l'homme est bien j'ai perdu les
clés de ma bagnole tu crois ça ben ça
c'est pas grave utaka dormir là au nom
écoute
oh je suis venu pour ton emprunté ta
caisse c'est à dire que je les ai amenés
hier à la révision
non pas le break je te parlais de quoi
je te la ramène demain promis c'est pour
une urgence sinon tu penses bien que je
me permettrai pas c'est pour faire une
virée avec caroline tu sais la blonde de
l'autre jour je lui dis que j'irai avec
elles visitent ellis island demain matin
j'en sais rien peut-être parce que c'est
ma maîtresse qui t'envoient en l'air
avec la blonde
ouais mais juste un copain bah je me
suis dit que pour une fois on pourrait
faire autre chose que coucher ensemble
parce que je ne suis pas très fier on
s'entend bien c'est pas le problème
je voulais juste varier les plaisirs
mais je lui ai proposé de faire un peu
de tourisme et phoebe elle aussi elle
s'envoie en l'air mais pas avec moi
sinon elle serait encore à la maison
tout ça pour dire une fois une caisse
c'est une voiture de collection
cela sort jamais de son garage c'est une
bagnole heurter quelque part dans les
entrailles de ce gros v8 une petite voix
qui n'est que j'ai envie drôle et
n'entend pas fait attention aux quais
encore merci je m'en voudrais à mon pote
aller disparaît reste qu'en première je
change de vitesse
[Musique]
tu demandes
on va faire
on va prendre
ça allait le cascadeur tient pour boire
at-on bon rétablissement au merci je me
suis cru au-dessus des lois
résultat je suis à l'hosto justement
pour ce qui est de la loi tu t'en tire
pas trop mal ça va pu être bien pire
genre prison au moment où on n'a pas
cette loi là celle de l'inertie tout
corps en mouvement garde la même vitesse
jusqu'à ce qu'il rencontre un objet au
repos dans mon cas c'est un platane et
quand je leur thé ça m'a stoppé net
ah ouais l'inertie bons rails à perth a
peut-être fait peut-être non merci serre
allez il faut que tu manges un peu on
m'a dit que tu avais eu que des
ecchymoses
si seulement la voiture avait eu autant
de chance vient pas ce que je m'en veux
pour ta bagnole je veux payer toutes les
réparations jusqu'au dernier centime
on s'en fout de la voiture d'accord je
sais combien tu y tenait quitte à donner
ça c'est le pizzaïolo se passe le
téléphone service d'étagé coûte
mais t'es dingue pourquoi tu lui
apporter ça c'est meilleur que la bouffe
de l'hosto mitumba abrutis je te parle
du champagne c'est irresponsable est
attaqué alors qu'il avait bu gens
savaient rien il débarque chez tour en
pleine nuit et tu trouves pas ça louche
ah ben quand même
il est dans la chambre d'en face au cas
où ça t'intéresserait si tu voyais les
tabacs pignol tu sais combien de temps
j'ai mis pour trouver un modèle de 65 en
bon état avec seulement 150 mille
kilomètres au compteur
j'ai laissé mon métier je veux dire j'ai
des relations étaient venus ici pour
quoi au juste voir michael ou consulter
des messages
on le prend merci nous a eu un
rendez-vous à 4h30
jeudi c'est tout ce qui restait qui a
rendez-vous
les gens qui l'aiment qui ne veulent pas
que la prochaine fois il se tue au
volant tâche d'être présent
francis scott fitzgerald edgar allan poe
jim thorpe le général grant hill à doha
d'un camp edith piaf
tous ces personnages célèbres avait
quelque chose en commun comme votre ami
il buvait pour se stimuler pour se
détendre ou pour tout autre excuse qu'il
trouvait il était actif et ont plutôt
bien réussi leur vie professionnelle
mais ils ont aussi fait souffrir leurs
proches et quand ceux ci ont voulu les
aider leur manquait une chose
essentielle mais laquelle une méthode
moi j'ai l'habitude de ça je suis
musicien chez nous quand atypique hall
on le croise à deux ou trois et on
l'insulté
on le rabaisse 7 infaillible comme état
d' mais il est vrai que certaines
interventions peuvent être assez mal
vécue cependant le but n'est pas de
rabaisser votre ami comme vous dites
mais de lui faire bien comprendre qu'il
faut qu'ils changent et que s'il ne le
fait pas il vous perdra tous vient serai
toujours là pour lui moi aussi permet la
partie
alors comment ça marche
au départ il faut trouver un lieu pour
notre intervention où il se rendra sans
aucune des finances
j'ai pensé à un truc il faudrait faire
le tri dans le grenier pour savoir ce qu
ont gardé ce qu'on jette
proposez-lui une activité à laquelle ils
se sentent obligés de participer samedi
midi c'est bon est ce que je te dis à
quel point tu manqué de voix déjà
eh bien je te le redis j'ai promis à un
rôle important à jouer
ses parents devront aussi être de la
partie depuis le printemps dernier
cette espèce de crétin éventrées dans un
arbre parce qu'il avait trop picolé n'a
pas entendu ce qu'il a dit au téléphone
et j'ai très bien entendu déjà qu'ils
font une petite fête en son honneur et
on est invités toi alors il ya des fois
vraiment où je me demande sur quelle
planète tu vis tu préfères quoi soie
mousseline et sans oublier ses collègues
de travail
ils sont gentils comme si j'avais rien
de plus important à faire ce week-end
c'est quoi des racines d'aubépine c'est
normal que ça sente le chat crevé il lui
exposeront les défauts qu'il a dans ce
domaine je suis sûr qu'une fois cuit
c'est délicieux vous avez parlé d'une
mais presque aussi surprenant que ça
paraisse hell bourg et de la tribu les
délais une petite minute
dois-je comprendre que sa femme est au
courant pour moi désolé ça m'a échappé
j'étais nerveux et est ce qu'il sait
qu'elle sait pas encore le par ailleurs
je vous conseille de noter ce que vous
aurez à lui dire
et dans ces moments là on perd
facilement ses brillants soyez brest
quelques phrases sur deux dont 2 je te
dis tu veux pas qu'ils occupent et là
au vu comment elle est toujours aussi
mince bonjour bien entendu je serai là
pour accueillir les participants
j'expliquerai quelles sont nos buts tout
en structurant et en orientant le débat
où est ce qu'il est du calme je suis sûr
qu'il va arriver d'un instant à l'autre
appelle le qu'on sache si les parties
tête qui s'est pas réveillé on en a fait
aussi les interventions avec mon unité
au nicaragua je ne pense pas que michael
ait le moindre problème
sinon il m'en aurait parlé au panama je
crois qu'avec ce que j'ai là je vais
faire mouche c'est gentil au début et
caustique sur la frais si jamais ça
sonne dans le vide alors le bipe
on avait une mission et on s'en
acquittait et caroline au fait ne nous
avait pas dit que tu l'avais invité l
était pas sûr de venir
artix tu as une nouvelle petite amie
c'est sérieux vous deux
[Musique]
ce serait possible de mettre la
climatisation un peu plus fort comment
va ta mère stuart quelle femme adorable
on s'entendait bien toutes les deux en
or et sa coiffure tu te souviens jack
elle avait la même coupe que marie
c'était d'un chic
ma mère nous a quittés malheur toutes
mes condoléances
pourquoi tu ne m'a rien dit ça s'est
passé quand j'étais en troisième et vous
êtes allé à son enterrement sur mince
alors excusez moi te demander ça mais et
ton père il est toujours vivant que ce
que ce vous faire franchement je me
souviens très bien de lui qu'est ce
qu'il est et grands au moins deux mètres
il avait fait une tarte aux pêches pour
le concours de pâtisserie titre apple
jack
c'était le seul à avoir participé veine
maintenant ça suffit
je sais qu'on doit faire court mais tout
à coup j'ai plein d'idées qui me
viennent jeu qu'il faut que je t'ai vue
là je ne crois pas ça qu'il est dehors
qu'est ce que je disais n'en a pas le
docteur michael je reconnais sa voiture
michael est là si on trouve pas une
explication on est mal a entendu ça
michael la chérie bon on fait quoi
maintenant
et si on se cacher
[Musique]
allez salut mon chat surprise si nous
sommes tous réunis ici aujourd'hui c'est
pour intervenir dans ta vie enfin c'est
ce qui est prévu avec l'aide d'un
spécialiste qui qui qui qui va bientôt
arriver
tu comprends après ce que tu as fait à
la voiture non pas que ce soit à cause
de ça uniquement un atout c'est chris
compenser toi sur une feuille et on va
te lire c'est du lourd
il nous fait venir de phoenix c'est
sûrement pas parce que tu t'es fait
obtenu seul beau qu'est ce qui se passe
rien du tout alors je leur ai bien dit
qu'il commettait une erreur je te
connais je n'ai quatre gardés pour
savoir si quelque chose ne va pas il a
je crois que tu sens très bonne santé
well as raison écoute parce qu'ils
disent c'est des conneries qui veut du
thé
[Musique]
alors là bravo vous avez tout fait
foirer bon écoutez moi le week-end n'est
pas perdue maintenant qu'on est tous là
autant rester je propose qu'on aille
faire une partie de golf puis qu'on
mange tous ensemble comme une famille
normale qu'est ce que tu en penses jack
dia
[Musique]
et il revient merde pas c'est bon sinon
il faut savoir s'il était parti est ce
que je peux te voir de me dit c'est une
blague ou quoi
tu m'as dit que tu voulais qu'on vide le
grenier tous les deux je suis venu ici
pour t&d en pensant qu'on ferait aussi
l'amour si jamais de lachor si tu rends
compte que tu as failli mourir
bon d'accord je bois un coup de temps en
temps et alors je dois vraiment pascal
mal à ça quoi c'est très important comme
un autre une minute c'est pour ça que tu
veux qu'on se sépare
c'est à cause de ça parce que tout est
un nouveau mec vous préférez siroter du
jus de fruits à l'apéro tu m'a plaqué
pour me remplacer par un gus qui boite
bonjour merci d'être venus
parisse et non par là et d'isoler fait
pas attention à nous ont fait passer on
peut pas dérangé venez les autres sont
déjà là le docteur nous a dit d'inviter
tous ceux qui sont proches de toi
le docteur n'est pas là comment ça se
fait vous inquiétez pas il sera là d'un
instant à l'autre
avant ce soir ce serait bien bonjour
ravi de vous rencontrer je suis la mère
de michael je tenais arty depuis qu'il
est tout petit avant ils avaient un peu
de mal avec les filles mais
manifestement ça n'est plus tard comme
les gens changent
est ce que quelqu'un peut aller
décrocher j'y vais c'est n'importe quoi
vous pouviez pas choisir pire invité
pour un pour votre réunion là parce
qu'on a déjà bu ensemble et même moi
j'arrivais pas à suivre c'est pas grave
quoi tu es libre de sortir avec qui tu
veux mais tu comprends rien je veux pas
être libre moi c'était pas sérieux avec
elles
j'avoue j'étais faible mais d'accord tu
veux pas discuter comment est ce que je
peux me racheter entre avec moi non
désolé il le faut parce que j'ai pas
envie que tu es un autre accident
tu comprends ça
pardon si je t'ai fait souffrir
pas dans la maison elle est tout le
monde t'attend
quoi qu'il en soit pour l'instant il est
toujours sous sédatifs
j'ai parfaitement conscience du problème
que ça pose pour l'intervention
mais on peut le faire par téléphone ce
que votre méthode tout aussi vous êtes
toujours là bonjour à tous bienvenue
chez les dingues maman bonjour mon grand
papa vous avez fait mon voyage
thomert russe où chaque elle a pris tout
son coeur d'europe
il peut rester alcoolique jeter rapporté
des cacahuètes de l'avion j'ai profité
que les hôtesses étaient occupées pour
en piqué elles soient toujours occupée
merci maman et ses faux papas mais on
dirait que je suis le seul à le penser
par deux voix là toi j'étais loin de
m'imaginer que tu m'en voulait à ce
point pour ta voiture
le docteur ne peut pas venir l'un de ses
patients a fait une tentative de suicide
il préfère rester à son chevet jusqu'à
ce que son état se stabilise il nous
conseille de commencer sans lui il a dit
de lire nos phrases et que peut-être il
arrivera un peu plus tard dans la
journée
peut-être
donc ce soi-disant docteur six ans lui
vous avez placé tous vos espoirs
un spécialiste qui s'occupe des gens qui
se pendent ce dès samedi faire enfin je
crois
et on vous l'a recommandé ou vous l'avez
trouvée dans les pages jaunes
le docteur trent est très réputé est un
domaine et saint vincent est un
excellent capitale on a eu de la chance
d'avoir un rendez vous avec lui
d'habitude il faut attendre des mois
pour faire des tentatives de suicide bon
alors on fait quoi
dit je sais pas pour vous autres mais
moi je commence à avoir faim gb sur
jolie et pourquoi on n'irait pas au
restaurant mes parents n'ont pas fait
tout ce chemin pour des surgelés
n'est ce pas n'est ce pas je connais une
très bonne adresse à lévis
il
j'adore quand tu nous emmènes c'est pour
ça que je garde la carte de membre j'ai
pas tout suivi on est là pour déjeuner
ou pour le truc le truc on peut le faire
aussi oui il ya des mariages
les parm in var c'est très festif comme
endroit
[Musique]
vous désirez un apéritif 3 et je vais
vous prendre un engagement d'haïti
réflexion faite
un cocktail sans alcool et vous monsieur
alors moi à soda je sens qu'à son une
limonade ci devrait vous gênez pas pour
moi si vous voulez boire de l'alcool
alesi moment tu prends une coupe de
champagne
soyons fous à lier evelyne quoi
finalement il votre père vous êtes qui
au juste
caroline est une amie à bout bien je
croyais qu'elle et arty finalement amené
moi gin tonic quel genre d'ami jack je
ne pense pas que ça nous si j'aime bien
savoir ce qui se passe depuis qu'on est
arrivé il nous laisse dans le flou le
plus total
caroline est une relation d'un mois
ainsi que phoebe les rapports humains ça
fait longtemps que je sais plus de les
comprendre et vous faites quoi vous
donner des cours de remise enfin makwaia
de vente à faire attention à sa ligne
écoutez il n'y a rien qui m'oblige à
reste je ne vous raconte pas dit si vous
voulez gk fermons la cus ont promis non
je vous en prie rester c'est important
que tout le monde soit là on a besoin de
chacun de vous est ce que je pourrais
avoir un verre de vin blanc
qu'est ce que tu fais comment ça tu
pourras jamais bien sûr que si voyons
pour les grandes occasions
je voudrais une grenadine s'il vous
plaît à moins que mes amis voient un
inconvénient
mike il faut que tu saches que
aujourd'hui si tu en as envie tu peux
boire
tu vas terre courageux fait que répéter
ce que le docteur a dit au téléphone ou
licence et se comportait comme à
l'accoutumée ça veut pas dire l'inciter
à boire s'inquiète je peux me contrôler
ça commence mal
quoi tu dis ça je suis là pas vrai
sagement assis à vous écouter et j'ai
c'est de considérer la situation de
votre point de vue je suis rentré dans
un arbre et vous tout de suite vous
appelez votre docteur pour organiser
cette espèce de réunions ce type i alors
si gentil de nous inquiéter mais si vous
voulez mon avis vous avez réagi de
manière un peu excessive
d'après le docteur trent c'était un
appel à l'aide et c'est drôle je croyais
que c'était un accident
il nous a aussi prévenu que tu te
tenterait de minimiser les choses
et qu'est ce qu'il a dit que je ferai
pas parce que je veux être original il
nous a dit que ce serait pas facile
cette réunion a un but bien précis
d'apporter notre aide
et si tu les refusent
alors nous nous verrons dans
l'obligation de couper les ponts avec
toi à notre grand regret il faut que tu
comprennes que c'est pas une
plaisanterie bon d'accord je vais jouer
le jeu je te remercie pour ces
précisions
bon on commente
j'ai eu le docteur et il a dit qu'on ne
pouvait plus reculer c'est maintenant ou
jamais c'est stuart qui animera les
débats
c'est le seul à s'être porté volontaire
alors tu connais cette chanson non mais
je parie que toi si j'adore les paroles
bien avant que je fasse la connaissance
bien avant qu'on se rencontre
je savais qu on s'aimerait comme nous
donne
tu m'accorder une danse
rick petite danse pour se détendre et
ensuite je suis à vous ils attendent et
on peut pas commencer sans toi c'est un
vrai cauchemar ce repas et tu en est
l'invité d'honneur
j'étais certain de bien voir apporter
vas-y lance toi quoi de tête mais en
fait j'ai beaucoup à dire et sans
menottes pour me guider dans ce cas là
qu'il passe son tour
non chacun doit prendre la parole bon
alors j'y vais ce n'est pas encore à son
tour peuple c'est pas toi par les masses
et pas d'âge il y à un ordre à respecter
mais je suis prêt je t'écoute jamais on
est censé prendre la parole l'un après
l'autre en tournant dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre
j'ai avant une coupe de champagne
ok ok c'est bon j'y vais de mémoire ça
donnait un truc du genre tu parles tu
travailles tu es un incapable
c'est tout
tout à l'heure vous avez écrit carrément
un dictionnaire est en fait je notais
les grandes lignes de mon discours quand
j'étais à la fac ont organisé des débats
d'idées
tous les jeudis et j'étais plutôt doué
je dois dire pour présenter le thème de
la soirée
mais dès qu'il fallait développer
c'était comme si la liaison entre mon
cerveau et ma bouche étaient
interrompues et soudain c'était le trou
noir
rien à voir avec le trac vous devenez
confus excuse moi ouais c'est pas pour
toi cette intervention
je comprends excusez moi en parlant d'
intervention attendrait bien besoin j'ai
commenté déglingué attendait et ce qu'il
a le droit de me parler comme ça non non
personne ne doit s'adresser à quelqu'un
d'autre
excepté à michael c'est pas une
discussion cela m'énerve chacun dit ce
qu'il a à dire un point c'est tout je
pense que vous buvez tout simplement
parce que vous êtes prisonnier de la
vision occidentale de la réussite à
savoir une échelle qu'il faut gravir
afin de justifier notre existence mais
si je peux me permettre je sais que vous
n'êtes pas d'ici mais sachez qu'en
amérique la réussite est une valeur
fondamentale
j'aime ce pays sûrement autant que vous
si ce n'est plus je peut réciter la
constitution et ses amendements dans
l'ordre croissant et des croissants
alors gardez vos remarques pour vous
michael tu es à l'inconscient tabou
ziéba poitiers moi j'ai écris tu as
toujours fait la fierté de tamam alors
que tu savais qu'elle comptait beaucoup
à mes yeux et ça ça n'est pas près de
changer un incapable je pense que boire
un verre il n'y a rien de tel pour se
détendre
tu sais que tu peux manger des pierres
sur n'écoute pas ce qui te raconte est
resté lucide est très bien comme têtue
et un danger pour tout changer rien et
les autres c'est tout ce que j'ai à lui
dire tu en est à combien de coktail jet
pas tes oignons retourne te soit ubac le
ton travail cependant lorsqu'on est
saoul il faut éviter de prendre le
volant
je comprends pas mais je préfère ça que
tu bouzid à santés point final
souviens-toi d'une chose et j'ai pas eu
à le noter a été chef de classe non
oui mon camp qu'est ce que tu me fais
michael tu n'es pas censé parler avant
que tout le monde est finie ne soit pas
si modeste joyon à sa rentrée en cp il a
eu un petit accident
je ne sais pas si c'était le stress ou
les pruneaux que je lui donnais pour
faciliter son transit toujours est il
que j'ai accouru à l'école avec un porte
à londres change et parce qu'il avait
été super courageux sa maîtresse l'a
nommé chef de classe
alors michael s'est adressé d'un air
autoritaire à tous ces petits monstres
qui se moquaient de lui en l'appelant
pue du cul et il les a fait taire
puis à midi il les a fait marcher en
rang jusqu'au réfectoire en séparant les
demi pensionnaires de ce qui avait amené
leur santé puis est ensuite il leur a
dit puis un soir tu m'a emmené manger
dans un nouveau restaurant sans savoir
qu'ils n'avaient pas encore
d'autorisation pour servir de l'alcool
et j'ai bien senti un malaise tout au
long du repas
c'était comme si tu comptais les
secondes avant de rentrer à la maison où
enfin qui pourrait prendre un digestif
voire plusieurs
et quand je t'ai vu comme ça j'ai eu mal
mal de savoir que sans ce petit quelque
chose en plus tu ne pouvais pas apprécié
le seul fait qu'on soit ensemble
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que tu avais à dire
attends je j'ai quelque chose à ajouter
il faut que tu saches que monsieur jeu
surtout pas de manif mais qu'est ce que
tu fais ça soit pas je lui chante la vie
risque d'asthme à bram à l'est avec des
cours de secourisme je sais tu vois ça
va que martin mois mais lui les bras au
dessus de la tête
ok respire il y en a sont vides et sa
vallée du cassoulet faut tu te détendre
relaxe je suis je j'aime ta femme genève
voilà c'est la seule qui me comprennent
est-ce que c'est lui c'est lui ton amant
voyons c'est absurde
jeannette a fallu michael
[Musique]
je m'en souviendrai celle là jamais on
m'avait viré des restos toutes ces fois
où il est venu à la maison et où je
faisais des gouffres
[Musique]
effectuez écoute-moi attends tu as fait
ce qu'il fallait
tu l'a envoyé à l'hôpital il ya eu ce
qu'il méritait est ce que c'est vrai
cette histoire le mec qui animait la
réunion où il se fait à femme passionnée
ok j'arrête là choix mais où tu vas à la
michael moi je comprends leur colère ils
nous détestent ça c'est sûr et fait
chier cas et qu'est ce que je dit je
vais rentrer avec les autres données
qu'est ce que je fais [ __ ] c'était
quoi ce traquenard
c'était une idée de ce soir unités à 0 à
moi les gars c'est la vérité et ses
cliques a invité la blonde j'ai été
désigné en fait et mes parents j'ai
quand même + 10 ans et l'histoire du
chef de classe ça vous a plu
tu es ma femme et mon pote mais tard
vous le saviez qu'ils étaient tous deux
sur toi mac
écoute moi bien ça peut arriver à tout
le monde d'être à fidel c'est bien
simple c'est même arrivé à ma femme
même à marjorie marjorie comment ça on
est en caroline du sud pour
l'anniversaire de sa grand mère elle
était partie se promener avec un de ses
cousins personne ne savait où il était
et moi j'aime elle a [ __ ] avec son
coussin s'te plaît ça arrive souvent
dans le sud
et après ils ont des gosses avec 12
orteils qu'est ce que tu fous là toi moi
rien je suis enfin bref comme marjorie
est revenu j'ai trouvé qu'elle avait une
drôle d'odeur
vous savez cette cette odeur de poisson
avarié
après ça pendant des semaines je pouvais
plus l'approcher ni même la touche et la
vache
moi si j'ai fait un blocage avec linda
linda la douce et jolie linde ouais j'ai
fait le con un soir j'étais atlantic
city avec mon groupe et avec le batteur
on est allé dans une boîte de nuit il y
avait un salon privé avec des danseuses
qui faisait des strip-teases je sais
j'aurais dû rester à l'hôtel et regarder
les chaînes pour adultes sur le câble
mais je vous jure
cette piste était un phénomène j'avais
jamais vu ça l'était d'une souplesse
elle mettait ses jambes derrière la tête
on aurait dit un joueur de près de celle
continue désolé
après ça je me suis sentie tellement
coupable vis-à-vis de gignac j'arrivais
plus apte et pourtant j'ai tout essayé
j'ai même été jusqu à l'imaginer en
strip-teaseuse
eh bien ça me faisait aucun effet tu
veux dire que tu as pas eu d'érection
pendant cinq mois c'est ça que tu
cherches pas fixée qu'est ce qui vous
prend les mecs un cousin une strip
teaseuse
où est passée l'époque où on n'avait
aucun secret l'un pour l'autre où on se
téléphonait pour se raconter notre
journée les progrès qu'on avait fait
avec nos copines leurs seins bien rond
et ferment tous ces longs mois
d'attentes avant d'atteindre enfin
paradis l'isaf est né à wez je me
souviens de la fête mais aussi qu'ils
apprennent celle qui m'a dépuceler moi
aussi oui mais c'est lui qui l'a eu en
premier et comme il était cool il y à
parler de nous j'ai pas eu besoin de lui
parler il cessa jeu sérieux vous lui
plaisier ok mais toi tu lui as plus
d'abord il n'y avait rien entre nous
quoi tu avant ça on n'a jamais couché
ensemble
mais alors qu'est ce que tu faisais avec
elle je me réservais pour brenda
nicholls brenda nicholls barriques
c'était la bombe du lycée par la pompe
tu déconnes elle était tellement poilus
qu'on l'a surnommée la guenon elle
connaissait haute sur une urne greg
barker 7 10 john keats comment j'adorais
ce poème elle me l'aurait si tu es en
expliquant comment la sortir la
reconnaître
reconnaître quoi la beauté quoi d'autre
à défaut de nous
pendant toute l'année de terminale tu
étais avec fait nerfs alors que tu
voulais te taper la clau
alors chacun ses goûts de toute façon
y'a prescription depuis le temps non
vous me foutais le cafard vous avez en
commun
toute une histoire c'est vrai moi j'ai
connu ça avec personne si seulement
j'avais des amis comme vous met en avant
qui peut très drôle je sais que tu ne
veux pas je veux essayer
ouais bien sûr bien là à les approches
[Musique]
les malades
et
oui
[Musique]
prenez ma caisse je rentrerai en taxi je
le sens mal
la raison c'est pas une bonne idée
michael wahaha quelle journée
et quelle soirée il a qu'à passer la
nuit chez toi et je vous retrouverai
demain dans le train ah ouais génial on
va bien se marrer
j'ai encore des tas de blaye elle est
scellé je vais te dire je me suis trompé
à ton sujet en fait des couilles des
mots héros rendez-vous dans le wagon
fumeurs m
appelez moi un jour mon numéro et dans
l'annuaire
j'allais faire retirer mais je me suis
dit hé comment on va trouver
c'est dingue comment je me suis
transformé je suis carrément à notre
homme a aspergé que ça va durer bon tu
montes dans la bagnole à j'arrive à rien
[Musique]
ça va ton bras elle dort ta femme voilée
baisse
je pars i kissed a rien dit michael est
chez pourquoi pour la même raison qu'il
a attendu d'être prêt en athlétisme
avant de lâcher le foot il prend jamais
de risques baisse ou est ce qu'elle est
michael copains tu as pu oser faire un
coup pareil je vais t'expliquer
d'abord la choix mais à part la faut que
je te montre de quelque chose baisse ma
plaque et elle est partie à cinq mois
avec les enfants devaient arriver et
c'est arrivé
bermex m'assois je suis un peu fatigué à
cause des antidouleurs que je prends
parce que tu m'as déboîté l'épaule
tu vis tout seul ici alors et en profite
pour baisser ma femme depuis cinq mois
je baise pas ta femme
ah bon et tu fais quoi avec elle d'une
shocking quoi un jour après le départ de
baisse on courait tu pleurais phoebe la
remarque et je lui raconter toute
l'histoire
on s'est trouvé des tas de choses en
commun je n'arrive pas à le croire
c'est bien que le lendemain
en l'acquittant je les embrasse et elle
m'a pas repousser alors gelé prise dans
mes bras quand on s'est séparés
on était amoureux je te crois pas qu'est
ce que tu as en commun avec ma femme
d'abord un on a perdu
elle s'est pas encore totalement fait à
l'idée mais mais moi depuis longtemps
déjà je le voyais venir jeter à ça fait
un bon moment que tu n'est plus que
l'ombre de tout même alors là je vois
pas du tout de quoi tu parles
- franck si j'ai tenté de la convaincre
de ne pas quitter mais mais je me suis
rendu compte que le coeur n'y était pas
et qui surtout pas besoin que tu prennes
la défense c'est pas un gros loser de
ton espèce qui s'est fait plaquer par sa
femme et qui va me c'est quoi ce à quoi
ces trucs se flinguent là un fly
d'accord et c'est pour te défendre
contre eux qui au juste
les souris un soir en sortant de la
clinique je me suis fait agresser peut
être paré au cas où ça se reproduirait
pas ce que tu fais là tu vois comme tu
as plus de femmes et aura jamais la
mienne et je crois qu'il vaut mieux que
je te le confisque va faire quoi rêve
mais rien tu sais bien que gérard ces
trucs là d un jeu devrait elle et moi
confiance et pas l'intention de me
suicider si tu le dis elle dit ok je
voulais être sûr j'apprécie ton
attention
[Musique]
tu aurais pas dû embrasser ma femme
même si elle n'a pas repoussé
tu as abusé c'est pas des trucs qui se
fondent entre potes quand on voit qu'un
copain va pas très bien la première
chose à faire c'est dû parler sinon à
quoi ça sert amitié
[Musique]
t'aurais pas quelque chose à le bar et
dans le salon je voulais juste un truc à
manger
[Musique]
je te fais pas confiance
il était très bien placé alors jouons
maintenant on n'est pas à la finale du
masters jamais je me suis sentie aussi
ridicule tous ces gens là qui disaient
leurs feuilles de mon temps quand on
buvait en garder pour soi ont convoqué
paul ban et l'arrière-ban crois moi si
j'avais eu mon mot à dire là dedans je
vous aurais jamais invités non pas que
ça m'ennuie que vous soyez là au
contraire ce que quand tu veux evelyne
et voilà
tu sais j'ai entendu dire que dans
certains car c'était génétique je ne
suis pas je ne veux surtout pas que tu
penses que c'est ta faute
ou tu peux en virement bien sûr que
cette sof août il avait qu'à pas mener
une vie de bord autre chose je crois que
ces bâtons de chaînes commencent à
barreaux de chaise ça se dit pour les
cigares tu fais allusion à quoi
exactement à l'alcoolisme
oui ben quoi j'ai entendu dire que ça
pouvait être une maladie héréditaire
ça vient pas de mon côté né du mien
dommage a bougé les hanches tablier le
bras droit est à relever la tête trop
tôt j'essaie
[Musique]
tu as la mémoire courte je me souviens
que son oncle avait aussi un sérieux
penchant pour la bouteille
une fois il était un abribus sous son
imperméable il était complètement nulle
passait rien
il a attendu et au moment où est passé à
un groupe de majorettes il a ouvert son
à perth et des racontars excuse moi mais
question aurait dit été pas mal non plus
à commencer par ses cachets que du globe
comme si c'était des bombes sous emprise
commencer par médicaments que j'ai eu
sur ordonnance si je les prends c'est
parce qu'il ya une raison parle de trucs
a été très mal d'avoir les nerfs
fragiles
michael a hérité une aversion à l'effort
chez toi vous êtes tous nés avec une
cuillère d'argent dans la bouche et puis
tu verras jamais personne de ma famille
faire des séjours dans cette espèce de
deux cliniques pour les dingues
enfin moi ce n'est pas une clinique
c'est un centre de remise en forme au
bord de la mer débats rencontres
protéger l'état reproduit le même schéma
avec ton gamin
résultat il est aussi bizarre que toi
notre fils fait de son mieux pour s'en
sortir
et pour quelqu'un qui a un aussi grave
problème que l'alcoolisme
il se débrouille pas si mal
[Musique]
n'arrive pas mal c'est l'histoire des
rois et des princes
quelle histoire le tombé raconte là moi
ça va pas de pleurs dis toujours on
verra maintenant que tu es attisé ma
curiosité c'est trop tard je veux savoir
fondé tous nos espoirs sur toi bah quoi
c'était une grave erreur linéraire
comment ça se passait au moyen âge quand
le roi était vieux le trône revenait à
son fils aîné mais il en avait d'autres
comme ça en cas de problème on pouvait
toujours remplacer l'héritier elle y
peut rien la pauvre elle était trop
fragile
elle a failli jeter par la fenêtre le
lendemain de ta naissance c'était trop
risqué de faire un autre enfant
si on en avait eu 1 peut-être que lui au
moins reçu quoi faire de sa vie et qu'on
aurait été fier de lui
c'est toi qui insistait
c'est dingue
je pensais qu'on aurait eu plus de
choses à se raconter on est une famille
faut améliorer des coûts de proches tu
devrais reprendre des leçons
[Musique]
tu sais je me dis que je suis pas un cas
désespéré j'ai rien à voir avec mon père
tu penses pas que ta décision a été un
peu trop hâtives j'ignorais que stuart
avait un don pour embrasser
mais c'est quelqu'un de bien mais je
comprends pourquoi tu t'es tournés vers
lui ils adressent pas si bien que ça et
ce n'est pas lui d'ailleurs il s'agit
d'une autre personne enfin ce n'est pas
une vraie personne du moins pas encore
mais je me doute qu'une fois qu'elle
sera là j'aurais du mal à me recaser
quand je l' ai appris je ne savais pas
trop quoi faire
j'attends un bébé
[Musique]
tu me prévient que maintenant ça veut
dire que si j'étais pas venu de voir ça
que j'ai décidé de te quitter pour vivre
pleinement ma grossesse je pas passer à
côté
mais enfin chibi
je n'aurai pas la force de m'occuper de
deux enfants à la fois
laisse moi au moins de montrer de
changer tu vas où reste là
tu devrais penser à se reposer et faire
un peu plus attention à sa santé
quoi rien qu'un baiser
tout ça pour un vieux roulage de patin
et renoir tu peux te les garder c'est
pas ça qui va nous aider
il n'est pas chez lui est bon d alors
peut-être qu'il est quelque part à new
york dans sa voiture est garée devant la
maison
ou alors il se promène il a disparu
depuis 3h tête bien qu'il est parti
faire une grande balade je vois pas
pourquoi tu flippes parce que personne
ne sait où il est et aussi qu'il a mon
arme
mais enfin comment est ce qu'il a pu
avoir accès à une arme sont à recevoir
de vous d'accord parce que je vous
rappelle que si on en est arrivé là
c'est de votre faute
on est venu à votre cabinet ça nous a
coûté 200 dollars vous l'avez lu ou
votre diplôme dans une pochette surprise
on a bien d'accord je vous ai dit pour
mon autre patient il est entre la vie et
la mort
je ne suis pas dans mon assiette il est
perturbé il marqué plus que ça quel
poids à votre place je mettrai tout en
oeuvre pour le retrouver parce qu'il
semble que ce soir la tendance soit au
suicide
alors qu'est-ce qu'il dit excusez moi ce
n'est pas le terme que je voulais
utiliser et oublier ce que j'ai dit
d'accord ce n'est pas grave je peux vous
aider par téléphone mais c'est pas vrai
non mais je rêve
mais qu'est ce qu'il a dit j'y peux rien
c'est cet abruti de médecins que tu
engagé il a dit qu'il voulait m'aider
par téléphone j'y peux rien en plus
c'est michael m'a pris mon flingue sans
parler de ton enviée malsaine de te
taper la fan de ce que je ressens ce
pour elle n'a rien à voir là dedans oui
bah moi et c'est clair que si tu as fais
tout ça c'était uniquement pour te
débarrasser de son rival dans sa quête
rival tu le sais très bien
michael cheney alors tu as mis en scène
cette espèce de procès avec tous ses
proches et même si tu en avais pas
entièrement conscient va le retrouver au
quai il suffit d'être méthodique et qui
sait même pas où tu vas ça fait des
heures contours mais toi sur le bas-côté
fait conduire et toi je te dis je vois
où ça tient ou messenger
getting to know you get into like you
get me l'a juste un coup dans le nez lui
michael salle eu lieu tiens ça alors
waouh ya toute l'équipe et vous êtes en
retard pour l'entraînement à l'errance
et chaud si on est là c'est parce que on
se fait du souci
stuart a perdu son flingue et on se
demandait si c'était pas toi qui l'avais
away
c'est celui-là oui c'est lui éviter
d'ajouter comme single we done le je
tiens à m'excuser auprès de toi pour
tout le mal que j'ai pu le faire
je sais que je me suis mal comportés et
je le regrette sincèrement je t'en prie
deux mois ce flingue d'accord et vous
croyez que je vais me faire sauter la
cervelle
il faut que je vous montre quelque chose
est sûre si bâle elles sont toutes là
compter les là franchement vous pensez
que je me baladerai avec un flingue dans
ma poche
un peu de sérieux c'est devenu parano ou
quoi ouais tu as raison on est parano
sais rien allez bon j'ai une idée qu'est
ce qu'on est tous là et si on poussait
notre cri de guerre tu ferais mieux de
rentrer chez toi tu es fatigué a tant
fait pas pour moi je pète la forme
approché et c'est parti pour le tri bien
pour qu'ils encourent pour qu'ils
encourent pour ses coéquipiers
voilà c'est ça comment on gagne tous
ensemble
jusqu'où on est prêt à courir aller
jusqu'où on est prêt à courir je vous
écoute jusqu'au bout ouais exactement
jusqu'à ce qu'on crève il ya bon il se
fait tard là tu viens on va être
accompagnés
outre amène chez toi ok qu'est ce que tu
veux que je fasse chez moi ah les belles
voitures elle a très bien qu'à rentrer à
pied alors venez leur entrée tout seul
j'ai une proposition bien plus marrante
à vous faire et je vous explique la
règle du jeu
j'en ai cinq balles et genlis une dedans
allah vous voulez toujours rentrée
qu'est-ce qu'il nous fait là il est 10
heures j'ai pas envie d'aller chez moi
j'en faisais un 100 m
j'ai le pistolet du starter aux caisses
au départ je m'échauffe et michael
michael arrête tu vas blessés
tétouan rabat joie fais pas ci fais pas
ça en dirait ma mère écoutait yeux
à propos de ce compte a dit à ce repas
ou cescut sion avec ces sites est pas du
tout notre attention
on est désolé on s'excuse on est désolé
nommé tu t'entends par les petits à
participer avec eux maintenant tu
assumes pas allez hop tu dégages je veux
pas d'un dégonflé dans mon équipe
si tu cours avec moi autant me tirait
directement une balle dans le pied
maintenant 90 ou pas sa gueule mais le
coût email laisse moi t'aimer je connais
un endroit où on pourra te soigner au
toi ta gueule c'est comme même embrassé
ma femme se rappelle rien que pour ça je
devrais exploser les burnes ou la
cervelle
qu'est-ce que tu choisis
et vient de voir maintenant quoi ça te
marrer tu as complètement perdu la tête
et toi tu as perdu après je me tire on
peut pas les 6es bon copain et vous
aller dans le mauvais sens là c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va gagner c'est pas drôle
auquel cas je n'ai pas été là et nakheel
mon pote je t'en prie arrêt non je vais
courir avec toi dans le bon sens je te
demande juste deux mois serait pas le
père ben pourquoi tu ciel comme ça on
tiens toi europe 1 qu'il arrive quoi que
ce soit 1
l'ennui c'est avec vous ils n'arrivent
jamais rien vous savez ce que ça me
donne envie de faire mal tout moi de me
tirer une balle grand coeur non non
répond maintenant ça tu avanceras croit
d'entonner l'air de rien mais vous devez
comprendre mais j'ai la rage
oui j'ai en moi la rage de vivre vous la
vie aussi et puis vous l'avez tous perdu
qu'est ce que je raconte
il faut vous l'aviez jamais il y avait
toujours quelqu'un ou quelque chose qui
vous rappelait et aujourd'hui voilà le
résultat
ça sort ses poubelles ça fait sa prière
du soir
vous êtes blasé c'est tout vous dites
que je vois trop mes cheveux s'emmerde
je préfère de loin mon quotidien aux
vôtres et c'est simple si je devais
vivre comme vous vous savez ce que je
ferai
[Musique]
quelque chose qu'il se montre et l as
cannes on vendra gars mais regardez vous
vous êtes déjà bien avant d'avoir vécu
hors piste et seniors sauve-moi de
chéraga montre moi la voix
et attendez je veux bien vous donner une
dernière chance vous voulez intégrer
l'équipe et je vais vous montrer comment
alors je vais vous montrer la voie remet
et c'est à vous que je parle
vous allez m'écouter bond dans celles où
est ce que vous allez un robin c'est pas
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
on
m
[Musique]
docteur traite
oui
il ya une heure le respirateur
artificiel nous a lâchés sincèrement
navré et moi dont je ne crois pas qu'on
se connaisse vous êtes de la famille
vous aviez organisé une intervention
pour moi et vous est jamais venu je vous
présente toutes mes excuses
est ce que je peut vous être utile en
quoi que ce soit en fait j'aurais voulu
discuter avec lui
je vous demande pardon peut-être qu'il
aurait pu m'expliquer deux ou trois
trucs veut dire ce qui pousse quelqu'un
à vouloir en finir
quand on survit comment on trouve une
autre façon de bordés les choses vous
savez il est souvent autre chose
derrière l'alcoolisme
c'est ce que je m'évertue à expliquer
mon entourage le plus important c'est de
savoir où on va au lycée j'avais
toujours un but gagner la prochaine
course se trouver une nouvelle copine
partir à la découverte d'endroits où
j'avais jamais mis les pieds
j'avais hâte de me lever le matin
l'avenir me semblait radieux
et puis je suis devenu vieux jeu les
même pas vu venir
soudain j'ai commencé à voir les choses
tout en gris mais moi j'aime le blue
océan et quand je buvais le gris je le
voyais plus j'avais la pêche et les gens
m'aimaient comme ça du moins à l'époque
mais la vie comme elle est la fille des
gens ordinaires
comment dire je trouve que ça craint
certains se contentent des petits
bonheurs de la vie j'ai jamais pu me
résoudre petits bonheurs mon père
je fonctionne comme ça depuis tellement
longtemps si j'arrête sepa sepa
j'ai peur
[Musique]
de plus savoir qui je suis
où
oui
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour je te laissais mes
coordonnées j'entre dans le service du
docteur trent 6e étage vue sur un mur
pas de mini bar difficile de trouver
pire pour passer ses vacances
[Musique]
on n'a pas droit aux visites les 15
premiers jo mais après ça s'est donné
l'envi de chez viendrait dire si c'est
pas trop dur
tu es vraiment une femme magnifique
et si cet entretien de toi je me fais
pas de souci pour son avenir
je crois que c'est le mieux qu'on puisse
espérer pour l'instant
[Musique]
notre hangar
shi
[Musique]
et
le monde amateur
[Musique]
on pensait que c'était fichu à cause de
ses chaussures de son âge mais en le
voyant courir ce matin là on a compris
qu'on était encore loin de l'égaler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour qu'ils encourraient pour qu'ils
encourent pour ses coéquipiers
comment gagner tous ensemble
[Musique]
jusqu'où on est prêt à courir
allez jusqu'où on est prêt à courir tous
écoutent jusqu'au bout exactement ce
qu'on crève
[Musique]